[Music]
welcome back to Entertainment Tonight as
we remember the late great Debbie
Reynolds you know she was just 19 years
old when she got her first movie role
and even that you could see the makings
of a future superstar tonight we
remember Debbie in her own words we were
a poor family and my dreams were kind of
came through when I went to the see this
cinema Debbie was a true movie star from
the classic Golden Age of Hollywood she
grew up idolizing movie stars her big
break came in 1952 singing in the rain
she was a young unknown who was chosen
to be the leading lady to Gene Kelly who
was a megastar at the time what team
taught me was tremendous discipline and
never give up and you're never good
enough and he believed that I could do
it but I had never danced before singing
in the rain and I had to learn how to
dance and I this Little Miss Burbank
comes in three months I was like caught
locked in a sound stage to get me up to
being even able to never equal but at
least to cut the roll Jimmy Jimmy ten
she became one of the biggest stars of
the 1950s and 60s
I just feel my life has been really
blessed because being in show business
you know I've met wonderful people I've
traveled all over the world I ain't down
yet and I've had a wonderful life and I
still have more life to go best of all
it's just living with yourself
maybe I'm getting there she began her
career as an ingenue but developed into
a mature sexy leading lady her only
Oscar nomination came from the
Unsinkable Molly Brown that ship may be
down but not me Debbie had a close
relationship with her daughter Carrie
whom she was very proud of my daughter
Carrie Fisher who's in Star Wars and you
probably know that well they were kind
of raised on old films and Carrie runs
all these old films now even more than
the new film but losing her beloved
daughter may have been too much to bear
Debbie will be remembered as glamorous
and feisty a woman who lived in the
spotlight and seemed to enjoy every
minute with fame comes adulation that
means fans and they're going to follow
you and you have to learn to be able to
give up a little bit of you for that
and that that's your dream to want to be
successful then that's what you have to
give up
[Music]
you